i've talked about for a long time that
amazon is going to open source and they
did
sort of the quick checkouts but there is
something
happening here that is much deeper
today the wall street journal reported
that amazon is planning on opening
department store style physical
locations in the us
that's right
department stores the news came as
amazon passed walmart as the world's
largest retail seller outside of china
and that was just reported in the new
york times this week the latest
information from emarketer which doesn't
do their own research i think they
accumulate other people so i'll have to
see who the source of this is
shows that amazon will account for
41.4 percent of all u.s e-commerce sales
in 2021 whereas walmart will account for
only 7.2 percent
uh and it says here in their notes
um yeah we're going to have to check on
the e-marketer research because my
understanding when and you can leave
this in the program we should always be
careful with emarketer
because they were using other people's
information but maybe this is their
proprietary information so we want to
make sure we give proper credit uh leave
that in the show i just wanna i want you
to know how the sausage is made here um
so the wall street journal notes people
familiar with the matter in quotes
believe amazon exists is expanding into
physical locations to help grow sales in
areas like apparel home items
electronics and other similar areas kind
of makes sense right if you're gonna do
something like this
clothes or something that you know it's
one of the final things people like to
go to stores for and home items too
right so uh it's a great move by amazon
i think because brick and mortar could
not possibly be more
uh compromised during the pandemic
they're probably buying up spaces
for pennies on the dollar there is a
very simple way to look at this if
amazon was challenging walmart but with
a different product and then walmart
added amazon's product
that is a competitive threat to amazon
because then walmart can do things
amazon can't do what walmart can do is
what's called bricks and clicks uh you
may have been experiencing this i went
to the everlane store now i haven't
shopped at everlane a long time but i
needed a white belt and i was trying to
find a white pair of sneakers happened
to walk by one on south congress when i
was in uh austin for a wedding i was
like oh there's an everlane store and
then the next one was little lemon and
the next one was some other online store
i can't remember the name of it um but i
think lululemon i'm not sure if they
started as a as a retail brand but there
were a number of brands on south
congress that were
online brands that now had opened up
retail
stores
they asked me for my email and those
purchases were synced with my online
account now if i were to buy this [ __ ]
this shirt you know and know it's a size
you know three or whatever or nine and a
half in shoes
now i know that for that brand i'm gonna
be able to match that size same account
i can order with at home and all of my
billing and my ordering and my returns
can happen however i link them to like
them too if i'm at a wedding and i need
to pick something up today i can go to
the store use my same account if i go
home and i love the shoes and i want to
buy two more pairs in different colors
same size same account log in order them
i forgot what shoe was i forgot the
model boom i can do that and nike is
amazing and wonderful for online
ordering uh so is paige and vince those
are two other male brands that have
men's clothing that i like paige
p-a-i-g-e i think they started in uh
women's and then there's one called
vince v-i-n and c-e they make great
t-shirts so shout out to those folks for
stuff i like so wall street reported the
size of amazon's department stores
will be smaller than ones we see from
nordstrom and bloomingdale's those are
about a hundred thousand square feet
amazon scale done approach thirty
thousand square feet according to the
story by the way amazon already has 600
retail locations
that's because they bought whole foods
and they have 506 whole food locations
if they don't
do what walmart's doing walmart gets an
advantage and amazon does not want them
to have an advantage so
uh they also did this pilot program of
the 17 amazon fresh grocery stores
they've got 22 of these amazon go stores
um you know based on our quick research
here those are the cashier less ones
they've been testing and then i've been
in one of these they have these four
star stores i think i was one in la with
five more coming soon these are four
thousand square feet they're kind of
tweeners uh and
that feels like the size of like a lot
of like you know
local towns where you have a you know a
main street it feels like a main street
store and they basically have toys and
books and home goods devices it's great
for them to sell their hardware prices
like echo
um or their kindles and that kind of
stuff but it's a really nice experience
because they've kind of skimmed the
cream cream and it's a nice browsing
experience
and i guess they have 20 us bookstores
so i'm thinking amazon basics amazon
essentials will all be in these stores
and when they go to break up amazon
now amazon can just point and say listen
walmart's doing what we're doing
walmart doesn't allow third-party
sellers we do maybe you got to break up
walmart
right it's basically checkmate the only
thing that really
uh you know the ftc and the government
department of justice whoever winds up
uh going after amazon to break them up
the only real case they're going to have
is amazon web services versus
you know amazon uh the retailer and so
i think it would be logical for them to
break those two up because it will
unlock more shareholder value so um two
really interesting stories today and now
let's get on to our amazing interview
twilio is the cloud communication
platform used by
uber airbnb shopify and many others not
that you need any more names i mean
think about that uber airbnb shopify
basically as good as it gets you may
have heard of them in the news back in
november of 2020 when they announced
their 3.2 billion acquisition of segment
one of the world's leading customer data
platforms everybody knows segment if
you're in the industry well twilio
provides you the building blocks to add
messaging voice and video in your web
and mobile applications they are rooted
in startup culture and they are here to
help you on that journey twilio gives
you the power to build communication
apps easily so you can spend more time
focusing on accounts your customers
engage and delight your users while
scaling globally all from one api
powered platform from sms to voice to
whatsapp to email thanks to that send
grid acquisition and founder ceo jeff
lawson has been on this program multiple
times i think the last time was episode
967 back in 2019 let's book them again
and here's what you're going to get from
twilio startup program access to
webinars made exclusively for startups
and full support via the twilio startups
team a five hundred dollar getting
started credit and three thousand
dollars in send grid credits sign up now
twilio startups dot com slash twist
twilio
t-w-i-l-i-o startups.com slash twist so
go get the bag right now thirty five
hundred dollars in credits are waiting
there for you just take them twilio
startups.com twist